[Applaudissements]
8h30 sur LCI interview ce matin c'est
avec François Bayrou bonjour bonjour
vous êtes notamment président du MoDem
mère de Pau et vous avez veillé très
tard cette nuit 12 heures d'entretien
avec le chef de l'État les autres chefs
de partie ça a duré jusqu'à 3h du matin
la nuit est donc été très courte et déjà
ce matin on a quelques commentaires de
vos homologues des autres partis
eriksiotti pour les républicains qui dit
qu'il n'est pas convaincu pour l'heure
Olivier Faure du Parti socialiste qui
dit que personne ne peut estimer qu'il
en est sorti quelque chose et pour vous
succès ou échec cette rencontre c'était
très intéressant très original inédit
c'est la première fois que ça se faisait
et lorsque des opposants disent je ne
suis pas convaincu encore
traduit en français ça veut dire ça m'a
intéressé
il faut aller plus loin et c'est ce que
tous les participants ressentaient alors
c'est une réunion qui a été
tout à fait inédite dans son format vous
avez dit 12 heures de temps il y en aura
bien d'autres parce que vous insistez
sur le fait qu'ils ne sont que dans la
temporalité pas encore il y aura
d'autres rencontres il y aura d'autres
rencontres de cet ordre et on va en
parler ça a commencé peut-être pour se
représenter ce qui a été le caractère de
cet événement ça a commencé par
4 heures sur la politique étrangère où
il y avait plutôt un consensus sur tous
les parties du monde
ont été examinés et ce qui ne s'était
jamais produit et ne se serait jamais
produit
au travers du temps depuis les débuts de
la Cinquième République c'est qu'il y
avait un accord général
y compris de tous ceux qui n'avaient pas
soutenus l'Ukraine pour dire maintenant
il faut qu'on soit engagé et il n'y a
plus entre nous de débats sur
le soutien de l'Ukraine au Parlement
normalement le gouvernement informe le
Parlement sa politique on a un peu le
sentiment pardon mais c'était
incontournement du Parlement l'exécutif
les chefs de partie normalement c'est
une discussion entre élu et gouvernement
et bien le Parlement aura ses débats et
ses discussions comme c'est normal et
légitime il s'agit absolument pas
d'enlever quoi que ce soit au Parlement
mais pour vous mesurez bien le Parlement
depuis un an ce que les Français en ont
entendu c'est des affrontements
extrêmement violents des injures des
noms d'oiseaux dans un brouhaha
impossible à maîtriser cette nuit
c'était apaisé et c'était au contraire
très constructif apaisé avec par moments
de l'humour et c'est 4 heures sur la
politique étrangère ont permis à chacun
de mesurer les défis qui sont en face de
nous de notre pays
et d'une certaine manière en raison de
cette
réflexion approfondie sur ce qui se
passe dans le monde en Europe et dans le
monde
ça a donné à chacun un sentiment de
responsabilité plus importante
plus de gravité est-ce que pourtant
François le président a aussi dans cet
exercice accepter formellement des
propositions des oppositions il avait
dit qu'il était là il a fait plus que ça
il a il a donné plusieurs orientations
en indiquant que dans ce format là on
continuerait à approfondir plusieurs
sujets alors il y a un sujet il y a un
sujet social le la situation des très
bas salaires la situation de ceux qui
travaillent tout en étant dans des
secteurs ou les salaires sont
extrêmement bas donc il y aura une
conférence sociale de ce point de vue là
une réflexion
partager et il a accepté une grande
conférence démocratique sur nos
institutions sur le mode de scrutin vous
souvenez qui s'y était engagé depuis
l'élection présidentielle que vous ne
faites il y a pas que la conférence
sociale sur les salaires sur les
institutions c'est ce que le président
de la République a dit et il a même dit
que ça serait dans ce format qu'on
pourrait étudier
le mode de scrutin
les précautions à prendre pour que nos
institutions soient
à la hauteur de ce que nous sommes en
train de vivre et qui est complètement
inédit vous voyez bien que tous les pays
du monde autour de nous tous les pays
d'Europe je parle même pas de tous les
pays d'Afrique qui sont secoués de coups
d'état de jour en jour de coup d'État en
coup d'État j'espère
ça veut dire proportionnel c'est-à-dire
que le président le président de la
République alors tous les partis qui
étaient là je crois pas me tromper en
disant tous
nous dit la proportionnelle ça nous
intéresse c'est votre engagement ou
est-ce qu'on en est je rappelle que
c'est aussi une on a parlé des
référendums alors juste sur la
proportion est-ce que le président parce
que c'est important aussi il a écouté
est-ce qu'il a donné son avis est-ce
qu'il a dit j'y suis favorable il a dit
c'est un engagement que j'ai pris nous
allons l'examiner ensemble vous souvenez
qu'il avait parlé d'une conférence
transpartisane sur les institutions et
cette conférence elle était là on a
parlé du périmètre des collectivités
locales on est dans un dans un
labyrinthe de collectivités locales ou
personne ne personne pour faire les
sujets par an ce qui sont effectivement
d'ampleur très inconséquentes le
référendum c'est un sujet par exemple
qui est demandé par certaines
oppositions je mets de côté même la
question d'immigration n'y reviendra
mais sur le principe du référendum
est-ce que le président a pris un
engagement à ce qu'il compte en faire ou
est-ce qu'il a pris l'engagement de ne
pas en faire est-ce qu'il a dit quelque
chose il a dit formellement qu'il avait
l'intention qu'on clarifie cette
question entre nous qu'est-ce que
c'était qu'est-ce que que ça veut dire
vous savez que des responsables ont
parlé de référendum à choix multiple le
porte par le gouvernement parler de
préférendum référence et référendum donc
c'était néologisme
pour la circonstance l'idée a été retenu
et
l'idée a été non seulement évoqué mais
acté par le Président de la République
il veut approfondir cette question du
préfère un homme comme non non il a dit
que c'était pas son idée que que mais
que qui savaient pas ce que ce que
c'était mais qu'on allait approfondir
tout ça donc on écarte le préférendum et
on approfondit le référendum c'est ce
que vous nous dites essayons de pas être
trop simpliste
tout le monde a le droit d'amener une
idée
la question a été posée par exemple du
nombre de signatures qu'il faut pour
obtenir un référendum d'initiative de la
société
le référendum d'initiative partagée
parlementaires c'est pas que des
avantages regardons bien les choses en
face parce que des mouvements d'humeur
de l'opinion peuvent tout d'un coup
entraîner des changements dont on est
pas sûr qu'il serait les bons mais on va
approfondir ces questions qu'est-ce qui
se passe en réalité il se passe que nous
ne nous n'avions pas pris la mesure tous
ensemble
à l'exception de certains naturellement
mais nous n'avions pas pris la mesure de
ce qu'était l'exigence du pluralisme en
France c'est-à-dire vous voyez bien à
quel point aujourd'hui
autrefois on avait deux camps les pour
et les contre la gauche et la droite et
tout ceci a volé en éclat on a
asseyez-vous autour de la table de
famille et mettez sur la table la
question du vaccin ou la question du
changement ou la question et tout d'un
coup vous avez des affrontements qui
sont parfois tellement passionnelle
qu'ils en deviennent excessifs mais le
référendum c'est binaire c'est oui ou
non est-ce que
vous vous voyez bien que d'autres idées
avaient été émises pour que ça ne soit
pas oui ou non mais juste pardon je
m'arrête est-ce que vous vous considérez
que c'est une bonne idée de référendum
oui je pense que il est nécessaire
lorsqu'on est devant déblocage lorsqu'on
est dans des situations
dont on ne peut pas sortir par la voix
parlementaire ordinaire parce que vous
voyez bien que que les décisions
n'arrivent pas à être prises alors il
est légitime de faire appel au peuple
encore faut-il que ce soit de grands
sujets qu'ils soient parfaitement
expliqué vous savez bien que j'ai
insisté sur la pédagogie sur la sur la
sur les retraites j'ai un
sentiment de regret profond parce que on
n'a pas expliqué aux Français qu'elle
était quels étaient les le jeu et
quelles étaient les données de la
décision à prendre
les grands pour l'instant le référendum
c'est défini par la Constitution pour un
certain nombre de sujets économiques et
sociaux ou bien sur des sujets qui ont
été adoptés par la voix parlementaire on
fait une loi et on peut la soumettre au
référendum si les deux chambres
assemblés nationales et Sénat
s'accordent qui aura bien un travail
pour élargir le champ du référendum
éventuellement donc modifier la
Constitution c'est le ce que le
président de la République et ce qui
était assis autour de la table tous
ce qui est frappant
c'est que avant cette réunion
probablement la plupart des observateurs
et la plupart de ceux qui allaient y
participer avait l'impression qu'on
comprenait pas de quoi il s'agissait que
c'était inimaginable que les
affrontements étaient tels qu'on pouvait
qu'on pouvait pas avancer et tout d'un
coup on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait un
chemin au moins pour qu'on discute
ensemble
des fondamentaux pas d'un texte mais de
manière
constructive des passionnés j'allais
dire civiques éducation civique
éducation du citoyen une discussion
civique
où chacun dans sa responsabilité et avec
ses propres idées
accepte de confronter son sentiment son
engagement avec le sentiment et
l'engagement des autres qui ne sont pas
de votre de votre opinion qu'est-ce qui
se joue est-ce qu'on en parle de
l'avenir du quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron de l'avenir de la France de la
démocratie à quel niveau vous placez
l'enjeu vous savez que je suis
commissaire-plan par ailleurs et que
l'horizon du plan c'est 10 20 30 ans et
c'est de de ces décennies qui viennent
qu'il est question en réalité on a
l'impression qu'il s'agit de sujets
d'actualité c'est pas vrai on passe d'un
temps dans lequel on avait
des affrontements simpliste au temps où
on est obligé de prendre en compte le
pluralisme des Français et nous avons
une très grande chance la France parce
que selon moi là j'ai exprime mon
opinion parce que les autres pays qui
nous entourent
ils sont très souvent conduits à des
blocages de grandes démocratie autour de
nous les Pays-Bas la Belgique souvent
se retrouvent pendant des mois et des
mois bloqués en France nous avons et
c'est ce qu'on voulut les créateurs de
la Cinquième République en France nous
avons un arbitre et cet arbitre c'est le
président de la République élu au
suffrage universel par les Français
charge à lui
de tenir compte d'enregistrer ce qu'est
le pluralisme français ce que sont les
différentes tendances mais je vous
assure il y avait des moments personnels
aussi de manière de fonctionner
c'est un changement
j'y reviens il y avait des moments tout
à fait intéressants parce que quand vous
observiez en connaissant chacun des
acteurs autour de la table vous aviez
des signes d'un sentiment
de gens qui n'auraient jamais pu penser
se trouver d'accord sur quelque chose
par exemple dans la description de du
trouble du pays de ce qui s'est passé au
moment des entre guillemets émeutes de
ce qui s'est passé à ce moment-là vous
voyez les différentes sensibilités des
gens qui sont des extrêmes
des gens qui sont des extrêmes acharnés
les uns contre les autres en général
et puis contre le gouvernement
beaucoup de contre dans la vie politique
française
qui tout d'un coup disait ce qu'il dit
ou ce qu'elle dit c'est quelque chose de
profond et d'important pour nous au fond
ils ont partagé plus qu'ils ne croyait
pouvoir partager jamais vous
disiez c'est un moment important le
président doit la changer il y a eu des
tentatives à plusieurs fois il a dit se
réinventer a commencé par moi-même il y
a un an et vous êtes bien placé pour le
savoir il a lancé le Conseil national de
la refondation dont vous êtes le
secrétaire général des initiatives il y
en a eu d'autres est-ce que celle-ci
vient remplacer toutes les précédents
par exemple est-ce que le CNR disparaît
pas du tout
le président de la République je crois
va avoir l'occasion de le dire
c'est-à-dire que le CNR non seulement
ne s'efface pas mais va au contraire
prendre un rythme nouveau et des
responsabilités
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous décrivez
très bien les choses vous dites il y a
eu plusieurs il a fait plusieurs
tentatives en réalité le président de la
République cherche depuis des années à
renouveler le rapport entre les
puissants et les citoyens entre un
résultat la base de la pyramide ce
les gens de la vie de tous les jours les
salariés les retraités les chômeurs les
jeunes et les moins jeunes
la base de la pyramide sociale et ceux
qui ont des responsabilités de pouvoir
et depuis longtemps il porte cette idée
je puis en attester puisque nous avons
beaucoup travaillé avec lui ensemble sur
ce point il porte cette idée que il faut
renouveler ce lien là il faut remplacer
ce lien de défiance par un lien
au moins peut-être pas spontanément de
confiance mais au moins de prise au
sérieux ce que dit l'autre ce que sont
les responsabilités de l'autre et si on
arrive à faire ça en France alors on
aura
profondément changé la situation de la
démocratie française vous disiez à
l'instant François Bayrou en tant que
commissaire aux plans ce qui vous
intéresse aussi c'est de projeter le
pays à 10 ans et au-delà pas que les
sujets d'actualité il y a un sujet par
définition qui fait parfaitement le
point entre l'actualité et l'avenir
c'est l'immigration c'est un sujet
d'ampleur qui intéresse c'est beaucoup
des parties qui étaient présents hier
concrètement si là pour le compare du
très court terme il y a un projet de loi
qui doit être examiné au Parlement cet
objet c'est le Parlement il y a pas de
consensus est-ce que vous vous
considérez par exemple il faut sortir de
ce projet de loi les titres des séjours
pour les métiers en tension comme le nom
de la républicains ils sont opposés à
cette mesure alors ce que j'espère moi
c'est que le climat nouveau de
Saint-Denis puisque c'était à
Saint-Denis qui était la maison des
filles de la Légion d'honneur dans des
bâtiments absolument superbes que
j'ignorais pour moi pas
ce climat nouveau j'espère qu'il va
permettre
au Parlement différent
moi ma position elle est très claire
lorsque
quelqu'un venu d'ailleurs pousser par la
nécessité ou par des persécutions et
peut-être pas la nécessité qu'il vient
qu'il veut travailler
qui s'engage pour travailler qu'il
s'engage dans l'apprentissage de la
langue et qu'il s'engage c'est encore
plus profond que la langue qui s'engage
dans la dans la prise de conscience que
nous sommes un pays avec une culture on
a des manières de vivre on a des
manières d'être
qu'il faut respecter mais c'est ça un
pays titre de ces lorsque cela dans la
loi ça peut être une simple circulaire
plus tard je ne sais pas c'est au
ministre et au gouvernement de dire ça
pour la majorité et au Parlement de
l'examiner mais ce que je crois c'est
que cela on peut tout à fait
garantir leur place dans la société
française
doivent accepter le texte du
Gouvernement le gouvernement je ne donne
aucune leçon à qui que ce soit mais il
faudra bien trouver un compromis dans ce
cas là il n'existe pas aujourd'hui
mesurer ça lorsque vous passez d'un pays
en affrontement systématique
un pays vous acceptez de comprendre que
au fond comme dans une symphonie ou
comme dans un orgue
chaque
conviction
engagement et doit être respecté et que
c'est la confrontation avec les autres
qui va permettre y compris dans le
conflit la démocratie c'est jamais sans
conflit y compris dans
l'affrontement dans des mais ça c'est
cela qui permettra de sortir des
blocages que nous vivons depuis des
décennies
et tout ça
quel est l'objectif
ultime il y a quelques jours le ministre
de l'intérieur c'est beaucoup d'exprimer
Gérald Darmanin pour dire la victoire de
Marine Le Pen en 2027 et probable déjà
est-ce que vous reprendriez ce compte et
deux est-ce que tout ce qu'on fait là
aujourd'hui tout ce que vous faites là
aujourd'hui ça c'est objectif là
empêcher l'accession de Marine Le Pen au
pouvoir 27
ça dépend un enjeu partisan ou un enjeu
de de d'affrontement politique c'est pas
pour empêcher la victoire des uns la
victoire des autres si la France va bien
les choix qui seront les siens seront
des choix qui permettront de réunir les
Français pas de les opposer entre eux
voilà ma conviction personnelle et
profonde la question c'est est-ce que la
France peut se tirer des des immenses
risques qui sont devant elles en raison
de son histoire de sa manière d'être de
et qui sont devant tous les pays
d'Europe et du monde
aujourd'hui il y a pas un pays qui
puisse être défini comme serein tournez
vos regards vers la Russie hélas
vers la vers la guerre entre
d'affront de
d'offensive
d'agression entre la Russie et l'Ukraine
regardez la Chine regardez même l'Inde
regardez le Moyen-Orient regardez
l'Afrique
nous sommes en raison des immenses
bouleversements que nous sommes en train
de vivre de du numérique des images de
tout ce que vous vivez de votre métier
des passions que ça déchaîne qui sont
pas régulées nous sommes devant des
risques extraordinaires de fracture et
d'affrontement la question c'est est-ce
que nous pouvons résoudre ces fractures
vous savez les médecins quand ils
doivent résoudre une facture il
rapprochent ils essaient de faire en
sorte que sa cicatrise c'est exactement
cela l'enjeu l'enjeu c'est offrir à
notre pays une chance que les temps
aujourd'hui menacent une chance de s'en
sortir aussi bien et mieux que les
autres un dernier mot François Bayrou on
est en période de rentrée scolaire vous
avez été ministre l'éducation et le
dimanche dernier sur TF1 le ministre de
l'Éducation Gabriel Attal a annoncé
l'interdiction de la Baya dans tous les
établissements scolaires publics il y a
deux jours à votre place c'est la
secrétaire d'État à la ville s'abré d'un
grès stiroba je disais faisons une
expérimentation de l'uniforme à l'appel
sa tenue scolaire au moins dans les
quartiers politiques de la ville
qu'est-ce que vous vous dites NON je
pense que qu'il y a une demande comme ça
de l'opinion après je ne crois pas que
ça s'impose depuis le sommet je pense
qu'il faut que les établissements
s'expriment demandent que peut-être les
académies certaines académies
s'expriment et demandes je ne crois pas
qu'il c'est une petite nuance avec la
secrétaire d'État qui s'est exprimé je
crois pas du tout qu'il faille
limiter ça au quartier sensible au
quartier comme on dit de politique de la
ville c'est-à-dire ceux dans lesquels
les tensions sont les plus grandes il y
a aucune raison
s'il y a des demandes de cet ordre
il faut qu'elle touche
au cas par cas avec l'engagement mais
l'ensemble du territoire et l'ensemble
des établissements scolaires merci
beaucoup François Bayrou après cette
courte nuit d'avoir été invité de LCI